[Music]
hey what's up Wolfgang so today we got a
new TV spot trailer for ant-man and the
wasp it looks like they're doing sort of
the same thing that they did for
Infinity Ward coming out with these new
TV spot trailers every so often with a
little bit of new footage and just like
I did with Avengers infinity war I will
do the same thing with ant-man and the
wasp so here's the new TV spot trailer
for ant-man and the wasp we unleashed
something powerful HSU that is together
there is another person I can take maybe
I'm doing it wrong you have no idea what
I'm capable just wanted to give me a hug
wish me luck really
watch this
sorry I'm messing around
wish I had a suit
even with like minimal powers or maybe
even just a suit with no powers yeah so
there's a little bit of new footage in
this trailer but most of it is really
tailored toward the humor of the movie
but nonetheless there are a few scenes
in here that we can break down starting
with the first words that are said in
the trailer by hope Van Dyne stating we
unleashed something powerful she's
talking about ghost who is the main
villain in a man the wasp if you want to
know a lot about ghosts you can check
out the video I did on her not too long
ago and the link above but the main
thing you need to know about her is that
she can walk through walls she can turn
invisible most likely because she can in
the comics she is very skilled with
weapons and she's an excellent hacker
it's a pretty powerful combination so
yes you can definitely say that they
have released something powerful the
next scene is technically new but
doesn't necessarily tell us anything new
about the plot of the story
they're basically showing that they're
going to ask Lois for help which I'm
excited about because I really like his
character and he adds a lot of humor to
the film which is basically what they're
showing here as he tries to bring back
whatsapp
maybe I'm doing it wrong but the fact
that they actually need to call in more
help even though the wasp has showed up
to help ant-man means that ghost truly
is a very powerful character in this
movie the next news scene is ghost
saying you have no idea what I'm capable
of again you can check out my video on
ghost in the link above but basically
ghost in the comics started off as
someone who tries to take down major
corporations now ghost is actually from
the Iron Man comics and not ant-man on
the wasp so it's unclear what her origin
story will be but what I think that they
are referring to isn't this scene is
probably the fact that she has taken
down some corporations in the past by
hacking them and dismantling them from
the inside and now that she has to suit
granting her crazy strong powers she's
ridiculously strong now the next scene
again is just a funny scene it's ant-man
telling the wasp that she just wanted to
give me a hug wish me luck this is kind
of ant-man style even though he takes
things seriously he kind of does it at
the same time and that's what adds to
the humor of the movie and to the
character the next new scene is
man coming out of the ocean in his giant
form saying me eat people
and then this guy in the boat screams
and he says sorry just messing around
again they're trying to show that this
movie is funny that it is fun and the
last movie that we had out from Marvel
in the MCU was Avengers infinity war
which ended not so happily so it would
make sense that the next movie that
Marvel put out in the MCU because
Deadpool 2 is technically not in the MCU
yet would be funny and light-hearted and
again they go in to further demonstrate
this and the last new scene and the
final scene of the trailer where it's
Louise and hope and the Kearney says
wish I had a suit even with like minimal
powers or maybe even just a suit with no
powers in which hope replies no sorry
Louise but even though this is going to
be a fun and a funny and a light-hearted
movie it is going to be very important
and is majorly significant for Avengers
4 they're going to really explore the
quantum realm in this movie and that is
really heavily believed to be a key
factor in figuring out time travel for
Avengers 4 so that the Avengers can go
back in time and reverse Thanos a snap
so overall I think it's gonna be a great
movie I think it's gonna be really funny
and serious at the same time but it's
also gonna be really important for what
happens next in Avengers 4 well that's
it for this trailer breakdown ant-man
and the wasp comes out July 6 be sure to
subscribe to my channel to stay up to
date on ant-man on the wasp click that
like button if you enjoyed this video
and let me know your thoughts on Ant Man
and the wasp in the comments below
thanks for watching woof woof
[Music]
[Music]